I'm your host Daniel Dwyer join us ever
by Chris waters hey today Ronna Dylan
from Double Fine productions how's it
going you guys just keep pumping out
games yeah a lot of them big games
little games games that climb on rocks
please tell us about hack and slash hack
and slash is a action-adventure game but
it looks a lot like maybe a Zelda game
or a classic top-down kind of experience
but the mechanics are very different
everything is focused on hacking and
reverse engineering like the name of the
game yeah I'm saying - play on words it
is is play on words good alright let's
hop straight in your video game here I
want you to show me immediately why it
is not Zelda all right let's see so it
looks like somebody's already been
playing let's set up in the game um so
you guys just passed you're in early
access to the Mon correct yes we just
came out on early access this morning
sweet this morning kids
well thanks congratulate they mind you
coming in today well I was actually I
was I was pushing patches and bug fixes
just really before we can talk to you
how do you guys I hope it doesn't break
in the hour we're on live here yeah but
yeah so right from the beginning of the
game we you know we've been trapped in
this little cave and we're gonna pick up
this sword start our adventure but as
soon as we try and use our sword here
we're actually the tip is gonna pop off
at the USB stick there's a USB cable on
it which is definitely gonna date again
when we when we use this years I think
you're okay it's not like a minidisc
USB has been around for a while yeah
some staying power Universal baby so
it's got this it's got this little USB
tip on it and then when we find these
things at ports we can actually hack
them just a tip so we're actually
looking at the variables of this door
right here and none of the stuff is
faked it's like so when we set open the
true like we're actually modifying the
the actual memory on that object so the
variable in the game is actually called
Gate door or has a variable in it called
open and when you set it to true the
door slides okay
and that maids humorous variable name
creating difficult in your game it's
it's a yeah we have to play test the
variable names or
pretty extensively and yeah we
definitely have had some instances where
programmers have put funny things there
just because they know it's going to
show you but like you know this is this
push blocking it's kind of a normal
style of this block that weakens we
would see in a game like yes but and so
like you know adding some remaining
pushes so we can move it around some
more certainly useful but there's like
lots of other stuff looking in there too
like for no reason just because there's
a variable on the thing that's seconds
for pushes just a slide very silly wall
and get there yeah we're gonna meet our
gonna meet our buddy here his canonical
name is Bob will probably stick with
that call something else grace what
should call you guys our best friend is
this some sort of story exposition
that's happening here yes absolutely the
evil version of Bob yeah there's a patch
right yeah it's see it out of the
mustache is this like meant to answer
the questions what the evil was there to
do in their spare time like yeah there
we cut back to the wizard a lot to show
you what he's up to
what are you doing while he's not
actively trying to vex you or something
like that yeah exactly
Oh Bob what face oh oh she's super
excited about it yeah that typed in a
slash earlier too so we've got a little
bit I like that didn't break the game a
little bit it's all part of the bug
testing even here and I want to remind
folks at home or let them know actually
that we have we have some codes for hack
and slash we're giving away right now
I'm just on the stream and thank you so
much for bring them over there steam
codes for the early access if you are
windows bad boys follow us on at
GameSpot tweet hashtag GES the lobby
during this demo because we got so many
codes we're giving away today we got to
split them up in a section so if you
want to enhance lash by all means right
now hashtag jest allow the at gave so
I'll make sure you're following us as
well what what is going on with these
bushes what I mean I understand why the
rocks have you know what they what you
can edit the rocks before but what can
you do with our bush well so you know
these are these bushes like like any
good bush in a video game sometimes have
some hearts on them yeah but you know we
can we can add some hearts to it but
maybe you know just a ridiculous no
you're breaking this game you only have
three slots Brandon actually I'm full
right now this is holy I'm but doesn't
even I want to lets her the framerate a
little bit okay presumably all this
stuff is very much like introduced
introductory like showing you know have
this sort of main mechanic works how are
you stopping this game from like either
breaking on a mechanical basis or just
crashing it because you've populated
with too much stuff well the answer is
is that we don't necessarily stop that
stuff so like by the end of the game
you're actually modifying the source
code for the game itself okay in the
same way X values like just getting into
like there's a we actually have dungeons
that are procedurally generated from the
actual assembly so it will go into a
room that'll have these machines
connected by wires and you can like hack
the the parameter is not that kind of
stuff
but in the same way that when you're
modifying any source code you can
introduce crashes you can just guys
taken hearts I forgot that you don't
actually kill them yeah I was expecting
him to die when you hit him yeah like oh
you can also pack it but nope we're not
even gonna kill him we're just gonna
make it nice we just said as aggression
to false just gonna hang his little rock
dude that we can talk to you my face is
really cracking that was good yeah it's
usually our space I go for but this is a
family show you know he'd gamer asks is
the game procedurally generated or is
there a fixed story slash questi - do
you alluded to the procedural stuff how
much is in there well so the the main
game is is definitely like crafted
narrated a bit of content that we've
produced for it
procedurally generated the procedural
generation comes in by the end of the
game the stuff that you have access to
is basically the anything that's present
in the game so you can go into the code
for these turtles or the blocks or any
of that kind of stuff and so you can
imagine that like when you get modify
the code for those things there's any
number of things you can choose like
basically progressively like there's a
story that you're exploring but in terms
of what you're doing mechanic ways a
player as you get further and further
into it you're
really just manipulating things and
really really like deep ways so what's
happening here we plugged in this turtle
that we got flipped over so you could
make him to set up to a good faction it
looks like but could you also just make
him like a total demon turtle with like
movespeed a thousand and like perception
distance 2000 he just sees you wherever
you go and instantly is upon you yeah we
can definitely nefeli influence all of
that stuff
let's probably not do that because I'm
gonna get I just want to know that it's
possible yeah it absolutely is yeah
actually we can begin this like hang out
here like let's let's make him super
damaging like we goodness and we
actually the the speed at which this
stuff is updating is exponential so that
turtle gets one hit in he just destroyed
the entire world right let's also lets
them do explode on contact too and then
let's let's risk this we'll see if I can
get him the Smashing of his block again
oh it's fortunately didn't have to do
with 5,000 damage to himself and via
I'll show you another cool trick that
you can do to like you can push these
blocks and you can set how far they push
but if you're clever you can actually
set it to a negative value and now
you're pulling it and a lot of the stuff
we didn't anticipate like is just all
the variables on these things and then
that we've sort of discovered these cool
properties how long have you been
working on disc am i right in thinking
this was from amnesia for bites back in
2012
that's correct was the original
prototype was during that yes and that
was when Costume Quest was up as well
no across some trust was from my
previous I'll detonate a fortnight but
actually our buddies the Space Bags team
was from that same oh cool and they're
already out in early access as well but
yeah they came from that same period and
we've been working on the game the full
version of the game probably for about a
year
excellent I'm skipping through this
dialogue a little fast folks in the
there's a chatter really digging at a
lot of questions asking what systems
it's coming out on so it's PC Mac and
Linux and that's available on early
access today
cool how much of the game is currently
accessible so the everything except for
the final dungeon of the game
already in place we're holding back the
final dungeon specifically so that we
can get some feedback from players about
okay except that's working really well
so we can turn those puzzles to be nice
and challenge I like that chasing Aurora
did a very similar thing they held back
the final chapter of the game I like I
kind of liked that version of already
access where you're getting a nice chunk
of the game but maybe the cherry on top
isn't in there well the I definitely
want to that especially as the stuff
gets more sophisticated later on like
you're I mean I play with this guy a
little bit let's I'll do one of my
favorite things to do to these guys
which is we can we can come in here and
we can so things get more sophisticated
than just variables very like you know
his behavior is actually controlled by
this a trade harder right and so we can
come in here and reprogram them so the
like and I make him spin around for
forever like let's have them turn and
idle for a little bit we'll put him on
our team so it doesn't get mad at us I
can do a little bit of breakdown same
for us do you want do you anticipate the
people gonna play this and you're
actually going to like inspire people to
start coding for themselves I hope so I
mean I think actually the there's an
important distinction in the sense that
thing is about hacking more so than code
right yeah like you'll never actually be
typing a line of code in this game it's
all about sort of analyzing the the
algorithms and balloons and stuff and
manipulating them in interesting ways
but I definitely think people get be
able to get some keen insights into how
their games work and think about those
things a little more deeply it's one of
the more interesting things to me about
it absolutely let's uh let's have some
fun with this guy - so you let's have
him keep attacking us but let's make his
damage negative and he'll just follow us
around and heal us so we can go fight
some turtles and run into him or
whatever but my little bird will keep
making us healthy so there's all kinds
of you just waited here a second bird
yeah he's got a really hilarious he's
got very angry flying in he is but you
know it's not always about appearances
yeah is always about the coach it's
about what is variable can you any at
any stage change the textures to like
just the JPEG that you have in your
downloads folder picture of dogecoin or
something I was actually very careful
like we typically like very carefully
optimize and compress our textures and
all that yeah but I intentionally
avoided doing all that for this game so
you can actually just go poke through
the directories and look at our photo
oh really so you could theoretically if
it was the same similar memory size and
like resolution you can just swipe stuff
in yeah you can have like a brain to
face it till your heart's content it's
gonna be some real real salty looking
twitch streams that this game going out
there one of the things that we're
actually doing during early access is
working on the Steam Workshop
integration oh cool all right so so that
people can actually take some of those
fun modifications they make and publish
it into the world excellent people can
subject everybody there in dogecoin ass
could could folks out of certain stage
create their own sort of many adventures
with it laughs do you think that's like
not just within okay yeah I think that's
it really exciting I mean the engine is
very flexible because it has the beta
support all these legs we're still yeah
variables changing on the fly I'm really
curious is this guy a 56k modem yeah he
has a calls it Aria and 56k but
unfortunately it makes these Turtles
scared and so they dive into the water
so we're gonna have to know I keep
feeling - gonna have to see if you can
program something more melodious yeah
that would be a good something more
melodious voice and Tom's head asks a
question that I feel like we get
whenever people like a game and canvas
comment on the Vita are you guys looking
at scale terrible platforms the I mean
it's got a console heart you can play it
with a controller today I'm gonna set
his volume he still thinks he's turned
him up turn him up he still thinks he's
singing oh that's so tragic yeah pump it
up
we shut this back down all the beautiful
music of Internet connectivity I'm
getting like it I'm getting this like
feeling of anticipation over how much
this is costing me whenever I hear that
noise here my mom again or let's hear
your mom come in on the line don't you
have enough porn yeah but but yeah so
the it's got a console part too it's
obviously very it's the game is inspired
by my experiences of kid playing console
games and an emulator and hacking them
oh really
yeah totally and so that's where a lot
of these things come from but yeah so I
think we would definitely be interested
in how many consoles if we can and John
EF 536 asks can you die in this game and
I want to add something to that question
is there like an ability to like create
a hotkey for like quick loading quick
saving so you can like mess with stuff
see how it plays there and then go in
and try it a different way so this uh
this amulet that we actually got earlier
I kind of skipped through the dialogue
it was presenting it but this actually
goes all the way back in time so the
save file for the game actually doesn't
have it's not your current checkpoint
okay it's every change that's happened
over the course of the play alright okay
so for example if we if we work back to
if we travel through time-space to
librarians which is lay all that we just
came into we'll be back here in the
beginning of hmm and so when you die
that menu will come up and you'll be
able to navigate around if you find that
you hack something so that some puzzle
is completely unsolvable you can go back
in time to before you put that hack in
place and and and put things in shape so
yeah it's and also when the game crashes
because like crashes can be player
induced that's a menu will come up you
can navigate to just before you actually
modify that code to do that and this is
a fun puzzle too this is a password
puzzle and it's like you know the
videogames have taught us that the the
password is written on a note somewhere
and yes I'll just yes it might be in
this chest over here but
there's a little pasta going on let's
take a look at it
but you know someone wouldn't scratch
out the password it's not safe to write
down your password yeah I shouldn't do
that
yeah so but we see a couple of letters
there so we might be able to work this
out on this go how much of this game is
establishing tropes within the genre and
playing with them
there's a good chunk of the we try to we
don't break the fourth wall really like
the the fiction in this world is that it
just there are physics is sort of
governed by these algorithms some stuff
that you have the ability to control and
so like in a sense really and it's in
essence the wizard is a powerful wizard
because he's a powerful hacker right
it's not like you're going to be
fighting you're like resume that's in
your Documents folder but but there's
definitely a lot of stuff that like you
know it's using this kind of like
presentation of game is actually really
useful metaphor for players because you
know you you already know how it pushed
block works yeah then the kinds of
variables introduced will modify and so
like that gives you some grounding to go
start messing with that stuff and seeing
how you can push it in Johnson yeah
well those little lights lit up because
I'm typed in that w so we can we can
sort of brute force through this thing
and figure out what the actual password
is there's the high the Wizards had put
this wall in place so he uses a password
that's appropriate for him with their
rules number one now everyone knows my
passwords so though my textures are
broken they're now actually so what's
happened here is that somebody has come
in and corrupted to the swamp and
they've done it by taking this vat
that's supposed to heal it and setting
it to a large negative number so we're
gonna actually come in here and hack
this up to a healthy value and it's
gonna slowly clear up that corruption
if only Greenpeace can be so effective
the hack sword would make a lot of
aspects of life easier yeah I'm thinking
of you guys like fabric you have a hack
sword around the office as anyone
crafted an actual replica of this yes
yeah I really we haven't done this yet
but it's because it's got a USB I really
wanted little USB thumbdrive oh yes just
like the expert and the big top is the
broken top of the sword you know you can
just pop it off no big boom then it goes
in I wasn't thinking about merchandising
when we implemented that but yeah I
think it fits now but absolutely awesome
Brian and thank you so much for coming
in